What should I do?
Should I admit that I've made mistakes?
Should I remind you that I've done this before?
Should I give you a history lesson?
What should I do?
Should I tell you how much fun we had?
So, this went well.
Should I really believe I ruined my legacy?
What should I do?
Should I have my tattoo removed?
Wanna see my shiny new shoes?
Should I just sell shoes?
Shiny new shoes.
Or should I tell you, "I am not a role model"?
Hi, Chuck!
Seriously, what should I do?
Should I tell you I'm a championship chaser who did it for the money, rings?
Should I be who you want me to be?
Should I accept my role as a villain?
Maybe, I should just disappear.
Should I stop listening to my friends?
They're my friends.
Should I try acting?
You just gotta deal with the heat, man.
Be patient.
After a while, the temperature drops and everything is free and easy.
Should I be writing this down?
Uh-huh.
Should I make you laugh?
Should I read you a soulful poem?
Shoot me with your words, you may cut me with your eyes, but still, like air,...
...I'll rise.
Or should we just clear the decks and start over?
Coming through here.
What should I do?
Should I be who you want me to be?